Are you
Oh yeah.
Oh,
hey.
Well, the topic now is when trumpets
sound. And this is a very tricky subject
and there are so many views on the
trumpets that uh I don't think it would
be right to be dogmatic about it and say
this is exactly what it is. Let's look
at the various issues and see how it
fits in because we have lots to learn
and I'm sure there are many many things
in the book of Revelation
that uh will only become clearer as the
actual events unfold. Now many people
like to put the trumpets into the
future. There are whole schools of
thought on this but uh you have a
problem with the structure of the book
of revelation and uh we will see that
it's probably better to keep them in
line with the kayazm that structure
which was set in revelation so that we
shouldn't lose our place. So what are
these trumpets and what do they mean?
Now before we get to the trumpets, there
are first some interesting issues which
we pick up in Revelation chapter 7 all
the way through to 9 and they actually
form a unit. So I don't want to deal
just with the trumpets. I want to deal
with the package deal. So there's a
numbering of the people of the earth in
these subject in these subjects. So in
Revelation chapter 7 and in Revelation
chapter 9, there's a binding and a
loosing and they are related to four
angels.
In both sections, people are being
numbered. In Revelation chapter 7, the
people of God are being numbered. In
Revelation chapter 9, the demonic
counterpart is being numbered. So
there's a numbering. Those that are with
God, those that are against God. In both
the words are heard. I heard the number.
I heard the number. So he heard the
number of God's people. He heard the
number of those that are with the other
side. And of course you know that
statement, you are numbered and found
wanting. That's what we find in the Old
Testament. So it would be nice to be
numbered and not to be found wanting.
And the way to do that is to cling to
the Savior. So let's look at the
numbering of God's people in contrast to
the devil's people. You know what's
interesting? God always gives the
positive before he tells us about the
negative. Before we saw how the gospel
herald would be destroyed in the seven
seals, he gave us a picture of the
throne room with such awesome power. So
now here again, he's going to give us
the numbering of God's people.
As I said, this chapter is
parenthetical. It is put there in
brackets to tell us something about
God's people before he tells us again
about the worst things that are going to
happen. Who is able to stand is the
question. The answer is only the sealed
will be able to stand. So we would want
to know what that means. The numbering
of the people of God takes place just
before the close of probation prior to
the opening of the seventh seal. So in
other words, this is an issue that takes
place just before the coming of Christ
where there will be a final numbering of
the people of God. Obviously, God is
going to wait until the full number is
in because he told those symbolically
sleeping under the altar that they will
have to wait until the full number has
been brought in. Isn't that right? So
that's what the issue is about. And then
we get to revelation chapter 8 after
chapter 7 and it says and when he had
opened the seventh seal there was
silence in heaven about the space of
half an hour. So this chapter tells us
about the sealing event for the people
of God at the end. So let's go through
it. Revelation chapter 7. And after
these things, I saw four angels standing
on the four corners of the earth,
holding the four winds of the earth,
that the wind should not blow on the
earth, nor on the sea, nor on any tree.
Now, the sea, waters in the Bible are a
symbol of the nations. The earth is the
planet itself. The tree in the Bible is
a symbol of the individual.
Nebuchadnezzar was a tree that was cut
down. I saw the wicked flourishing like
green trees etc. So that's a symbol of
the individuals and these four heavenly
angels are holding back the winds of
strife
until God's people should have been
sealed. So the final destruction,
conflration on the earth, chaos that
will come is being held in check by God.
Irrespective of how bad it looks, God is
in control. That's what it says. So,
there are four angels holding the four
winds until God's full number had come
in.
And I saw another angel ascending from
the east, having the seal of the living
God. And he cried out with a loud voice
to the four angels to whom it was given
to hurt the earth and the sea, saying,
"Hurt not the earth, neither the sea,
nor the trees, till we have sealed the
servants of our God in their forids."
Now, what sits here in the forid?
The seat of your intelligence, the seat
of your decision makingaking capacity,
your consciousness. This is what sits
here in the forehead. This is what makes
a difference between us and any other
creature on this planet, any animal.
This is the great cognitive decision,
moral seat in the human being. And here
is where you make a decision for or
against something. And as we saw in the
previous one, to be sealed is to be
settled in the truth so that you cannot
be moved. But God also seals these
individuals. And I heard the number
there. We hear the number of them which
were sealed. So these are the people of
God. And they were sealed 144,000 of all
the tribes of the children of Israel.
Revelation 7:2-4. Now, some people like
to make this a literal number and say
there are literally 144,000 that are
sealed.
But remember, he heard the number. What
does it mean to be sealed?
Well, 2 Timothy 2:9, nevertheless, the
foundation of God standeth sure, having
this seal, that the Lord knoweth them
that are his.
So, he has sealed them.
And let everyone that nameth the name of
Christ depart from iniquity. So, what
does that tell you? These people have
made a decision to stop doing what is
wrong and to do what is right in the
strength of the Lord and to ask the Lord
for forgiveness for that which they have
done wrong and to ask for cleansing in
the blood of the lamb. Simple as that.
It's not a complicated issue. We always
make it more complicated than it is. And
the word over here for iniquity is
unrighteousness.
Injustice. Unrighteousness of heart and
life. a deed of violating law. Very
interesting. So if you depart from
iniquity, you become lawabiding. If you
love the Lord, you keep his
commandments.
Be ye angry and sin not. Let not the son
go down upon your wroth, neither give
place to the devil. Let him that stole
steal no more. But rather let him that
him labor working with his hands the
things which is good and that he may
have to give to them that needeth. Let
no corrupt communication proceed out of
your mouth. But that which is good to
use for edifying that it may minister
grace unto the hearers. It's not a very
complicated issue. It means start doing
what is right and give up what is bad
and grieve not the Holy Spirit of God
whereby ye are
sealed unto the day of redemption. So
people that are sealed have to start
doing what is right. They have to if
they were thieves stop stealing. If they
have a foul mouth they must clean up
their act. They must start doing what is
right in the strength of the Lord. Let
all bitterness and wroth and anger and
clamor and evil speaking be put away
from you with all malice. And be ye kind
one to another, tenderhearted, forgiving
one another, even as God for Christ's
sake has forgiven you. Ephesians
4:26-32.
It's not a complicated issue. Come back
into harmony with the law of God. That's
what it means.
Bind up the testimony.
seal the law amongst my disciples to the
law and to the testimony. If they speak
not according to this word, it is
because there is no light in them. You
cannot say, "I'm a child of God, but I
can live like I lived before." Uh-uh. To
the law and to the testimony.
I delight to do thy will, oh my God.
Yay, thy law is within my heart. Psalms
40:8. For this is the covenant that I
will make with the house of Israel after
those days, says the Lord. I will put my
laws in their
mind. Where's that? It's here in the
forest. And write them in their hearts
so that they can act accordingly. And I
will be to them a God, and they shall be
to me a people. Hebrews 8:10. We always
make these issues so complicated. It's
not that complicated. Do what is right
and leave the consequences to God. Now
in the heart of the law there is the
Sabbath. Remember the Sabbath to keep it
holy. Six days shalt thou labor and do
all thy work. But the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord thy God. Not the
third day, not the fourth day. The
seventh day is the Sabbath. In it shall
thou shalt not do any work, nor thou,
nor thy son, nor thy daughter, thy
manservant, thy maidservant, nor thy
cattle, nor the stranger that was within
thy gates. For in six days the Lord made
the heavens, the earth, the sea, and the
all that is in them in them. And he
rested on the seventh day. Wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day, and
hallowed it. So here in the Sabbath
commandment is another seal.
It says there in six days the Lord
that's the name Yave
made he's the creator heaven and earth
the sea and all that in them is so if we
look at Exodus 20 11 in six days the
Lord made the heavens the earth the sea
and all that is and he rested on the
seventh day wherefore the Lord blessed
the Sabbath day hallowed it he put it
aside for holy use and the word Rested
there means to give comfort, to be
confederate,
to lay, to let down, to be quiet. In
other words, to have a quiet moment with
God
in all this excitement on this earth.
Moreover, I also gave them my Sabbaths
to be a sign between me and them, that
they might know that I am the Lord that
sanctify them. Then hallow my Sabbaths,
and there shall be a sign between me and
you, that you may know that I am the
Lord your God.
Well, there are many gods out there.
Which one are you serving? The one that
you obey. How do you obey him? By
keeping his law. And if he said, "Honor
the seventh day," then which day should
you honor? The seventh day. Well, Exodus
31:13
also says, "The Sabbath is a sign
throughout your generations that you may
know which God you're serving." It's me.
I'm the Lord of the Sabbath. Hello, me.
Exodus 31:16. Wherefore the children of
Israel shall keep the Sabbath, to
observe the Sabbath throughout their
generation, for a perpetual covenant.
It is a sign between me and them that he
rested on the seventh day and he was
refreshed. Nafas interesting word
sign in the Hebrew is and it means a
mark. That's what the concordance says.
It means a mark, a distinguishing mark.
So what is the mark of God?
The Sabbath. Why? Because the Sabbath
ratifies the law. Without the Sabbath,
the whole of the Ten Commandments could
be from Joshmo.
Isn't that right? Could be from Joemo.
What if I had made Ten Commandments and
I sent them out and I said, "Everybody
keep them because I say so." What would
you do? You would think the man's gone
nuts, wouldn't you? But what if the
president of the country did it? If he
made a law and he said I want you to
keep these and I sign it and if you
don't well I have authority to do
something about it then it becomes a
little bit more important. Right? Now
what if the God of the universe says
boom I make this law in heaven and earth
it is to be
experienced as a perpetual law. Well
that's pretty authoritative. So if it
doesn't have that stamp of approval it
means nothing. So it is God's mark of
authority.
Does the beast also have a mark?
>> Yes, it also has a mark of authority.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
So, we must understand God's mark, his
sign or his seal. Just like a seal
authenticates a document, the president
of the United States, for example,
that's the seal of the American
president or the typical royal seal. It
says I, King so and so. the name, title,
king, territory, whatever it is, England
or
whatever. And right here in the
decalogue, there must be a stamp
authenticating the document. And you
find it in the Sabbath commandment.
Without the Sabbath, the whole of the
Ten Commandments is just another set of
laws made by who cares who.
but with the Sabbath commandment in it
has the name of the lawgiver and the
territory and its binding. So it
receives its authenticity.
And the Lord delivered to me two tablets
of stone written with the finger of God.
Deuteronomy 9:10.
There are only a few times when God
wrote with his finger. Did you know
that? Each time he wrote with a finger.
This is one of them. He wrote the Ten
Commandments with his own finger in
stone.
and he repeated it when Moses broke
them. So that's twice. And then when
the kingdom of Babylon came to an end,
God wrote with his finger against the
wall and the prophet Daniel said, "Many,
many tears."
Wow. That's what it means. Your kingdom
has been numbered and given to the Mes
and the Persians. It's another time that
God wrote when there was a judgment, a
final judgment which serves as a type of
what is coming. And there was another
time when God wrote in the sand.
That's when all the accusers came and
accused the certain lady Mary who had
been found in adultery.
And he stooped and he wrote with his
finger in the sand.
I wonder what he wrote there because
when they read it, they all turned away
and had nothing more to say.
He that is without sin, let him cast the
first stone. Maybe they saw written
things there they didn't really like to
read. Isn't it possible? Just for
interesting sake. So God's seal is in
the heart of his law. Remember the
Sabbath that keepeth holy. Six days you
shall labor and do all your work. But
the seventh is the Sabbath of the Lord
Yave your God. In six days, Yave, Lord
made, creator heaven and earth. There
you have it. The Lord creator heaven and
earth authenticating the whole document.
So it has his name, his title, his
territory.
I gave them my Sabbath to be a sign
between me and them that I am the Lord.
Now, how are we supposed to keep it?
Well, we read about that. not doing
thine own pleasure. It's amazing how few
rules there are on how to keep the
Sabbath. The Jews couldn't handle that,
so they made a couple of thousand on how
you're supposed to keep it. Instead of
leaving it to the conscience, not doing
thine own pleasure, that seems sensible,
calling it holy, honorable, honoring
him, not doing your own ways, finding
your own pleasure, speaking your own
words, delight yourself in the Lord. So
these are the positive things that come
out of the Sabbath. Not a day of misery.
By the way, today is the seventh day.
It's the Sabbath. Did we have a day of
misery so far? I haven't.
And was it only for the Jews? No. Also
the sons of the stranger that join
themselves to the Lord to serve him and
to love the name of the Lord to be
servants everyone that keepeth the
Sabbath. Even them will I bring to my
holy mountain and make them joyful in my
house of prayer. Wasn't a Jewish
Sabbath. In fact, it comes from Genesis.
It comes from creation.
For mine house shall be called the house
of prayer for all people. The Sabbath
was for everyone. Isaiah 56 verse 6 and
7. And it will be if you will listen
carefully to my commandments which I
command you today. Take heed to
yourselves that your heart may not be
deceived and then you go running after
other gods. It says bind them these
commandments as a sign upon your hand
and as frontlets between your eyes. Wow.
The commandments must be on the hand and
on the forehead. What does that mean?
So they wrote them out, stuck them over
here and bound them around their hands.
Job done. Do you think that's what God
had in mind?
>> I somehow don't think so. That's
ritualizing the law. And it might be
sincere, but it's not what is meant
here. It means think and act
accordingly. That's what God wants. And
God says his commandments must be in
your mind and in your actions. And
another power will come and says, "Ah,
my commandments in your minds or in your
actions."
Interesting distinction, but we're not
going to go into that. Deuteronomy says
the same thing on the hand or here on
the forehead.
And it'll be a memorial between thine
eyes and on the hand that the Lord's law
may be in your mouth. Exodus 13:9. So
God has something that must be sealed in
the mind, the law of God. And the
Sabbath is the sign thereof in a very
particular fashion. So the purpose of
the Sabbath was to be a day of rest, a
day of blessing, a day of peace, a sign,
a memorial to creation, a symbol of
sanctification, and a hallowed day, and
a perpetual covenant. Those were the
reasons why God gave the Sabbath so that
we shouldn't forget him. and what he has
done for us. And so the law of God in
its entirety with acknowledgment of his
authority in our lives will bring us
into harmony with heaven again through
the redemption which is in Christ Jesus.
And that is what it means to be sealed,
to come back into harmony with God. So
how many are sealed?
Revelation 7:5 out of the tribe of Judah
12,000. Reuben 12,000, Gad 12,000, Assa
12,000, Nephilim 12,000. And so we go
down through Manasi and Simeon and Levi
and Asaka and Zebulun and Joseph and
Benjamin. And they were all sealed.
12,000. So do you think it's a literal
number? Exactly 12,000 out of every
tribe. What about us then?
After this, I beheld, and lo, a great
multitude. You see, he heard the number,
but he looks and sees, he beholds, a
great multitude, which no man could
number of all the nations and kindreds
and people and tongues stood before the
throne and before the Lamb, clothed with
white robes and palms in their hands.
Some people make long discourses about
the 144,000 when the Bible doesn't tell
us very much about them. And seeing that
the whole book is symbolic,
obviously this is also symbolic because
we're going to run into trouble if it's
not. For example, if we look at the 12
tribes of Israel, then we'll see that uh
Levi is mentioned here in Genesis.
Joseph is mentioned over here. Levi is
also mentioned in Revelation over here.
and Joseph. In Ezekiel, we have the
tribe of Dan, which is not mentioned
over here at all, but it's mentioned it
in Genesis. We have Ephraim mentioned
here in Ezekiel, and we don't have
Ephraim mentioned here at all. So, which
tribes are you going to take? If you
want to make it literal, you're going to
be in trouble. Is nobody ever going to
be saved out of Ephraim and Dan?
Dan were pretty bad and they did funny
things, but there were lots that were
heroes from the tribe of Dan. Heroes. So
obviously it's a symbolic number and I
don't think we have to go any further
into it. It's a multitude of twelves.
For he is not a Jew which is one
outwardly, neither is that circumcision
which is outward in the flesh, but he is
a Jew which is one inwardly.
And circumcision is that of the heart in
the spirit and not in the letter whose
praise is not of men but of God. Romans
28 verse and 29. Is it only Jews that
are going to be saved from the literal
tribes? What about all the Gentiles that
have come in through the gospel herald?
So we cannot literalize the 144,000. And
in any case, who is a Jew? Who is a
Christian? It's one who is one inwardly.
Galatians 3:29 says, "If you be Christ's
then you be Abraham's seed and hes
according to the promise." So what does
that make us? That gives me a chance to
be
a seed of Abraham.
Abraham's seed and heirs according to
the promise if I accept Christ. Well, I
wasn't a Jew, so I was a pagan. But in
Christ, I can be Abraham's seed because
Christ is Abraham's seed. And if I am in
him, then I am redeemed. So now the
question of Jew or Christian is
irrelevant. If you have Christ, you are
Abraham's seed. No matter what your
circumstances of birth were. For in
Christ Jesus, neither circumcision
availth anything, nor uncircumcision,
but a new creature. And as many as walk
according to this rule, peace be on them
and mercy and upon the Israel of God.
Galatians 6:15-16.
So how do I become part of the Israel of
God of all ages?
I accept the lamb of God. A Jew was not
saved by keeping the law. He had to
bring a lamb and slaughter it. And he
was saved by the blood of the lamb.
Maybe he rejected the lamb later on, but
that was the method whereby he should be
atoned for,
and cried with a loud voice, saying,
"Salvation to our God, which siteth upon
the throne, and unto the Lamb." And all
the angels stood around about the
throne, and about the angels, and the
four beasts, and fell before the throne
on their faces, and they worshiped God,
saying, "Amen. and blessing and glory
and wisdom and thanksgiving and honor
and power and might be unto our God
forever and ever. Amen. Who wins?
Jesus wins. Again, we have this
wonderful theme where Jesus comes in the
revelation and he tells us about the
redeemed and how they are sealed,
settled in the truth that they cannot be
moved back in harmony with the law of
God, saved by the blood of the lamb.
And he gives us this beautiful picture
before he gives us the bad news. It's a
theme in the book of Revelation. You
never have to be afraid because he is
the victor of the King of Kings. And one
of the elders answered, saying unto me,
What are these which are arrayed in
white robes?
And whence come they?
And he said unto me, Sir, thou knowest?
And he said to me, "These are they which
came out of the great tribulation
and have washed their robes and made
them white in the blood of the lamb.
Therefore are they before the throne of
God and serve him day and night in his
temple. And he that sitth on the throne
shall dwell amongst them." That is the
conclusion of the matter. A great story
about victory in Jesus Christ before the
bad news comes.
They shall hunger no more, neither
thirst anymore, neither shall the sun
light on them, nor any heat. For the
Lamb which is in the midst of the throne
shall feed them, and shall lead them
unto living fountains of waters, and God
shall wipe away all tears from their
eyes. Isn't this great? Here's the
promise before the bad news.
And then comes Revelation 8.
And when he opened the seventh seal,
there was silence in heaven about space
of half an hour. We've dealt with this
text already. This is when Christ
returns. And I saw the seven angels
which stood before the before God. And
to them were given the seven trumpets.
Now come the seven trumpets. And people
say, "Well, this must be after the close
of probation." No, no, no.
All we had was a chapter which says,
"Listen folks, this is the outcome.
God's people will be redeemed by the
lamb and there will be no more tears and
this is the number of them and this is
what's going to be like." That's the
victory in the lamb. Now, let me give
you the bad news. This is what's going
to happen in history. And those that
reject the word of God and reject Jesus
Christ will also be numbered.
And sadly the number will look slightly
different.
Let's see what happened.
And I saw the seven angels which stood
before God and to them were given seven
trumpets.
And another angel came and stood at the
altar having a golden sensor. And there
was given unto him much incense. Where
is this angel standing? At which altar?
The altar of incense. The altar of
incense. Was it in the first chamber or
in the second chamber? It was in the
first chamber. So it cannot be after the
close of probation.
Jesus is still ministering in the first
chamber. There still has to come a
second chamber. And when that's
finished, it's over.
then it's too late. So here we are in
which part of the kayazm
the first part Jesus is still in the
holy place and many people want to take
these prophecies and throw them into the
future into the esqueological arm into
the endtime events portrayed in the book
of revelation and they violate the
kayazm. You cannot violate the kayazm.
You cannot tear something out of its
position and throw it where you want it.
You have to stay within the rules.
That's why it's written like that. So
you shouldn't be able to do that. So
much incense. There's the altar of
incense that you should offer it with
the prayers of all the saints upon the
golden altar which is before the throne.
That's the little altar that we're
talking about. And the smoke of the
incense which came with the prayers of
the saints ascended up before God out of
the angel's hand. There are people
praying. There is some need here still.
This is not after the close of probation
right at the end of time. No, no, this
is a continuous process. So would
suggest we follow the same process as
the others were. This is a pattern in
Bible prophecy. Book of Daniel does the
same thing. Daniel chapter 2 goes
through the history of mankind. Jan
Daniel chapter 7 recapitulates it in
another format. Daniel chapter 8 takes
it, recapitulates it in another format.
And so you have different views coming
to light. Same in the book of
revelation. You go through the seven
churches. This is the position of the
church. You go through the seven seals.
This is the position of the gospel
herald. Now we come to the trumpets
which are judgments
because there is a numbering and you are
found either wanting or you are found
righteous. Here is a judgment issue and
who is the judge? Jesus. He decides who
makes it and who doesn't. And he doesn't
neglect the prayers of the saints. It is
through his mediation that they are made
acceptable in the eyes of God. So the
merit of Jesus Christ is the issue here
at stake. The smoke of the incense which
came with the prayers of the saints
ascended up before God out of the
angel's hand. So the incense is a symbol
of the merit of Jesus Christ being added
to the saints making them acceptable in
the eyes of God. Wonderful image.
Everything is so loaded with meaning in
the book of Revelation. We could speak
for hours just on the symbolism here of
this altar of incense.
And the angel took the sensor and filled
it with fire from the altar and cast it
onto the earth.
Down it comes.
And there were voices and thunderings
and lightnings and an earthquake.
Revelation 8 verse 5.
Well,
judgments come upon the earth and after
the final judgments, just as Jesus died
on the cross and said, "It is finished,
so it will be done and it will be over
and the numbering will be done." And
either you are with the with the sheep
or you are with the goats depending on
your decision.
So what are these trumpets of
revelation?
There are seven trumpets and each one
herald something that happens here on
earth. Revelation 8:6. And the seven
angels which had the seven trumpets
prepared themselves to sound. Now let's
see what happens. Let me just
recapitulate here for you. The historic
arm had the seven churches, the seven
seals. And because we are still dealing
with altar of incense time, we are
dealing before the time that Jesus
enters into the most holy. So we're
dealing with the historic arm. They sit
in this side of the kayazm. And I cannot
remove them and throw them into that
side. That would violate the kayazm. Is
that clear? So obviously we are moving
through the same historic period that we
have had in the others. and to do
anything else would be contrary to the
system. And they all culminate of course
in the great climax of the coming of
Christ. So again, we're going to sweep
through history
and there is a parallel between what
happens during the blowing of the
trumpets and the seven last plagues.
This becomes an interesting point. So
the seven trumpets are blown before the
day of atonement and the seven last
plagues take place after the day of
atonement. In other words, when Christ
comes out of the most holy, then the
seventh last plagues will fall. So if we
look here at the trumpets, we'll find
that the following are affected. The
earth
8 chapter 8 verse 7 the sea chapter 8
verse 8 and 9 the rivers and the
fountains chapter 8 verse 10 and 11 sun
moon and stars chapter 8 verse 12 so
there's darkness bottomless pit locusts
come out 93-21
the river Euphrates 91321
loud voices the kingdom of Christ so
we've gone gone through a process and
every time a third a third a third a
third a third a third is affected.
If we look at the seven last plagues we
have a parallel. The first plague hits
the earth. The second one hits the sea.
The third one the rivers and the
fountains just like the seven trumpets.
Then the sun just as it was over there.
Darkness on the throne of the beast.
Then there's the river Euphrates which
you had over there. And then you have a
loud voice. It is done.
You see there's the it is done. So this
is what happens
after the close of probation
and this must happen before the close of
probation because it's only a third. A
third a third. It's not everything. a
portion is affected and there is room
for repentance
and it is in the mediation time when
Christ is serving in the heavenly
sanctuary in the first chamber. And
these are very important issues when we
deal with this because today there is
this tendency to take the trumpets and
to make them the same period or just
prior to this period over here. And
that's a problem because not only do you
violate the kayazm, you also violate the
component. There's only a component that
is destroyed.
Jesus Christ is in control. The number
of God's people, chapter 7,
now trumpets and the numbering of the
people of the earth and the problems
associated with it. Who is going to win?
Jesus or the other one? We already know
the answer. And therefore, we can relax
as we go through the trumpets. May the
Lord make us aware of the fact that
Jesus is in control.
When we're dealing with the actual
trumpets, it gets tricky because we
don't really have precise
ways of interpreting this. But let's
look at the various issues. This is a
very interesting study. Joel chapter 2
verse 15 and 17. 15-17 says, "Blow the
trumpet in Zion. Sanctify a fast, call a
solemn assembly, gather the people,
sanctify the congregation,
assemble the elders, gather the children
and those that suck the breast. Let the
bridegroom go forth of his chamber and
the bride out of her closet. Let the
priests, the ministers of the Lord, weep
between the porch and the altar, and let
them say, spare thy people, O Lord, and
give not thine heritage to reproach,
that the heathen should rule over them.
Wherefore should they say amongst the
people, where is their God? Here is a
situation where a trumpet is being blown
under circumstances where God's people
have obviously gone astray.
So let's have a look at the
interpretations. The first
interpretation
is that these trumpets are judgments in
our time paralleling the judgments of
the plagues.
That's a very prominent interpretation
in the world today.
Personally, I cannot accept that
particular interpretation for the very
reason that it violates the kayazm. It
violates the kayazm and throws into the
future that which is in the historic arm
of the book of revelation. Secondly, it
violates the principle that Jesus is
here not coming out of the most holy but
is obviously officiating in the holy
long before these plagues are going to
fall. So there are two principles why I
cannot accept that particular
interpretation.
Yes, there are contact points in that
the plagues are descriptive of the same
things that happen in the trumpets, but
the trumpets are partial and the plagues
are final and complete. So the judgments
are obviously judgments in time. So
judgments, the second way of looking at
it, retrace the periods of Christian
history covered in the seven churches
and the seven seals. That makes sense to
me at least. And some start well now now
the question arises where do you start
these judgments then who is being
judged?
Well some start with the judgments
against Jerusalem because Jerusalem are
the first ones who rejected Jesus Christ
and nailed him to a cross and there was
a judgment at the end.
God still gave them a space of time till
70 AD and then Jerusalem was destroyed.
Right? That's a judgment of God.
And
this is using Matthew 24 as a template.
That seems to me a logical thing to do
as well. Others again, they like to
start not with Jerusalem but with
judgments against Rome because Rome is
the power that actually nailed Jesus to
the cross. So here you have two opposing
views but really it's not such a big
deal as to whether the o one is
perfectly right or the other. The fact
of the matter is we are dealing with
judgments over the time. Personally I
prefer starting with Jerusalem because
that's also the template that is used by
Matthew 24. But I'm not going to make a
big deal if somebody doesn't want to
believe that and believe the other.
That's fine. Let's look at the first
trumpet. The first angel sounded and
they followed hail and fire mingled with
blood and they were cast upon the earth.
So here is judgment because parallels
also the hail at the end of time but in
a partial sense because a third part of
the trees the individuals were burnt up
and all the green grass was burnt up. So
here is a destruction of people. People
are being lost here. This is serious.
Why are they being lost? Well, the fall
of Jerusalem in AD.70
is the one possibility
and I've colorcoded them here. The
second possibility is that this is a
judgment on Rome. And the people that
favor this view say it starts with the
Visigoths that invaded Rome under all in
AD 396 to 428 and he paged Rome in AD
410 and the Roman Emperor Teodosius died
in AD 395.
So here we have a picture of the start
of the fall of the Roman Empire when uh
these various nations came in. Well,
this is a judgment that took place
absolutely
of this power that elevated itself even
over the prince of peace. But on the
other hand, the fall of Jerusalem is a
very powerful judgment after a long time
of probation
that said, well, you have rejected the
Messiah. These are the consequences. God
removes his protection. He allows the
wind to blow. And this is what happened.
And the second angel sounded as it were,
a great mountain burning with fire was
cast into the sea, and the third part of
the sea became blood, and a third part
of the creatures which were in the sea
and had life died, and a third part of
the ships were destroyed.
So now again, what does this represent?
What does this trumpet of judgment
represent? Well, again, we look at the
various uh interpretations. Mountains,
what do they represent? A great mountain
burning with fire. Well, a mountain
represents a nation in the Bible. You
can look that up in Isaiah chapter 2 2
and 3 11:94
41-15
Daniel 2:35 44 45 Ezekiel Zechariah all
of them have this picture of a mountain.
Let's look at a text in Jeremiah which
also brings this picture to the four.
Behold, I am against thee, oh destroying
mountain, speaking about Babylon, says
the Lord, which destroyth all the earth,
and I will stretch out mine hand upon
thee, and roll thee down from the rocks,
and will make thee a burnt mountain. So,
here's the symbol of a mountain that is
being destroyed. So the second angel
sounded and as it were a great mountain
burning with fire was cast into the sea.
So a nation in other words was scattered
amongst the nations. That's what it
would mean. And a third part of the sea
became blood. Sea is a symbol of waters.
The waters which you saw are peoples and
multitudes and nations and kings. So
bloodshed amongst this nation. And a
third part of the creatures which were
in the sea and had life died. And a
third part of the ships were destroyed.
Ship in the Bible is a symbol of the
economy. The ships of Katim. They are
economic uh symbols.
So let's have a look at the two possible
interpretation.
If the first one was judgment on
Jerusalem,
then the second one would obviously be
judgment on pagan Rome and the
associated nations, the sea. Jews and
Christians saw Imperial Rome as the new
Babylon. In fact, Peter even wrote a
letter where he said where Babylon is
because Rome like Babylon has destroyed
the temple and Jerusalem. So that is a a
reasonable assumption. On the other
hand, some believe that the second phase
of uh the vandal incursion into Rome and
the Jenseric 428 to 468
uh where the word vandalism comes from
derived from the vandals and they
pirated on ships on the Roman Empire and
paged Rome in AD 455. So some see this
as the symbol and others see it as the
encompassing the whole of pagan Rome.
Now whether you accept the one or the
other it's a matter of detail right it's
not something to make a great issue
about. It's not going to uh change your
salvation in any way. Personally I like
the first one more because it follows a
logical time sequence and frame. But it
doesn't matter if uh others prefer the
other one. Third trumpet.
And the third angel sounded, and there
fell a great star from heaven. Now, does
that ring a bell?
I'm sure it does. Did a star fall from
heaven at any stage? Yes. Lucifer fell
from heaven and he brought all his
demonic forces with him down here and he
was going to affect a great change. He
was going to take over this kingdom. He
wants to be the ruler. So false
teachings is what he brought with him.
Burnt as it were, burning as it were a
lamp. And it fell upon the third part of
the rivers and upon the fountains of
waters. These are also the peoples.
And the name of the star is called
wormwood,
bitterness.
And the third part of the waters became
wormwood. And many men died of the
waters because they were made bitter.
Now what does water represent besides
nations?
Have you heard of the water of life?
Now what happens when the water of life
becomes bitter? You see there was a time
period when there was compromise that
came in the third time period. Do you
remember that? Isn't this interesting?
Here's the third angel sounding. The
time of compromise. Didn't that turn the
waters of salvation into bitterness? Yes
or no?
Yes. And did people die because of it?
In a spiritual sense now, not in a
literal sense? Absolutely. Because if
you drink from this polluted fountain,
what is the result?
Death.
Eternal death. Separation from God.
So the great apostasy of the spiritual
leadership of the Christian church is
the one possibility that we have over
here. The falling away as Satan fell
from heaven with a third of the angels.
So the church would apostasize through
idolatry. Wormwood was used by Moses as
a symbol of idolatry in Deuteronomy
29:17 to18. Let's read it. and ye have
seen their abominations,
and their idols, wood, stone, silver,
gold, which were among them, lest there
should be amongst you man or woman or
family or tribe whose hearts turneth
away this day from the Lord our God, to
go and serve the gods of these nations,
lest there should be among you a root
that beareth gormwood.
Isn't that a great symbol?
So I kind of favor this because it's the
same time period. You have the third
angel. There was the period of the black
horse. That was the period of compromise
when the gospel was undermined and the
waters went bitter and people that drank
this new gospel
died a spiritual death.
Well, the other interpretation would be
that the invasion of the Roman Empire by
the Huns under the leadership of Aillaa
in the fifth century. So again, you have
an interpretation that it still deals
with the um Roman Empire as such. Of
course, this takes place in the Roman
Empire, so there's no problem. But this
is the one that just sort of gels it and
brings it into line with all the others
that we have seen paralleling them so
far. And you have all the symbols that
make this u seem to be that way. Now the
fourth trumpet and the fourth angel
sounded and the third part of the sun
was smitten.
Now the sun, what is that? The light of
the world. and a third part of the moon
and a third part of the stars. So as the
third part of them was darkened and the
day shone not for a third part of it and
the night likewise. This is not total
darkness as in the plagues. This is
a third part.
Revelation 8:12. Let's look at Micah 3 6
and 7 and see if we can pick up a
parallel. Therefore, night shall be unto
you that you shall not have a vision,
and it shall be dark unto you that you
shall not divine, and the sun shall go
down over the prophets, and the day
shall be dark over them. Then shall the
seers be ashamed, and the divine is
confounded. Yay, they shall all cover
their lips, for there is no answer of
God.
Doesn't this sound like a time of
spiritual darkness? Yes or no? Well,
what did they call the age of the next
dispensation, if you like? Didn't they
call it the dark ages? Yes or no? So,
who ruled in the dark ages once the dark
horse had changed into a horse of death?
It's the same time period. I believe
we're just following the same classical
period. And again, if you remove Jesus,
the son of righteousness, from the
gospel and make him less than he is,
then you die a spiritual death. That's
the that's the problem. How did they
remove Jesus from the heart of the
gospel? This is the scariest story of
deception in the history of the world.
After this lecture, we're going to go
into the details and we're going to have
a look at what they did. And I want to
tell you that today the whole world is
deceived into believing something
that is not from God. Scary. Scary.
So the two interpretations that we have
possible here, the darkness represents
the dark ages. That makes sense to me.
When truth was thrown to the ground and
the ministry of Jesus
was replaced by the ministry of the
church.
When Jesus was crucified, a literal
darkness covered the earth. Isn't that
right?
And serves as a type of the spiritual
crucifific crucifixion of Christ. The
reformation of the 16th century ended
the dark ages. That's basically what
this interpretation would mean. Now,
another interpretation would still be
with judgments on Rome. The sun, the
moon and the stars have been interpreted
as the luminaries of the western Roman
Empire. The emperor, the senators, the
consul. With the extinction of the
western Roman Empire in AD 476, the last
Roman emperor, Romulus Augustulus was
dethroned by order of Odoakar, the
Italian remnant. So that's one
interpretation. We have another judgment
here on the uh Western Roman Empire.
But uh this one over here to me
represents
a model that is in line with everything
that we've seen gone before. But I'd
like to know you to note something and
that is that in this time period of the
dark ages, Jesus is crucified again.
It's interesting
that the crucifixion there keeps him on
the cross and that's where the dark ages
would like him. But Jesus has been
raised from the dead and he rules in
heaven. Now it is also interesting that
to remove Jesus
from the system sometimes required even
the creation of an entire new religion
which would take Jesus away.
Very interesting. For behold the
darkness shall cover the earth and gross
darkness the people but the Lord shall
arise upon thee and his glory shall be
seen upon thee. Isaiah 60:2 great
darkness on this earth. Then spoke Jesus
again unto them, saying,"I am the light
of the world. He that followeth me shall
not walk in darkness, but shall have the
light of life." The issue is Christ or
not Christ.
I am come a light into the world that
whosoever
believeth on me should not abide in
darkness.
John 12 verse 46. The issue is Jesus or
no Jesus. Those are the issues.
Now comes an fascinating part.
Revelation 8:13. And I beheld and heard
an angel flying through the midst of
heaven saying with a loud voice, "Wo,
wo, wo!" Three woes to the inhabitants
of the earth by reason of the other
voices of the trumpets of the three
angels which are yet to sound.
Now comes a great woe. Now a woe is
something that hits mankind and has dire
consequences.
Now some people like to apply the woes
to God's people.
On the other hand, the woes could apply
to those who are being lost. And who are
we dealing with under the trumpets?
under the people of God that are being
numbered or under the others that are
being numbered.
We're dealing with those others that are
being numbered. So now we know what the
last woe is for sure because the last
woe is the coming of Christ and the
destruction of the wicked. So who does
it hit the last woe? The wicked. The
wicked, not God's people. Hits the
wicked. So why not the other two as
well? This is judgments on those that
have either been deceived and allowed
themselves to be deceived because they
reject light
or who just reject God outward directly.
So three woes are going to hit the the
inhabitants of the earth and a woe
deprivives them of salvation.
So the inhabitants of the earth by
reason of the other voices of the
trumpets will suffer from these woes. So
the three woes associated with the next
three trumpets imply an unprecedented
increase in demonic attack on the truth.
Nevertheless,
God is in control. So during these next
three trumpets, God is going to give us
a glimpse of what is happening here on
this earth.
It's scary and it will require 12 whole
lectures
to make us see what is happening. Wow.
We're going to do 12 lectures on what
this entails.
Scary. Wo, wo, wo was pronounced upon a
church who walked in the sparks of their
own kindling. who did not derive their
light and power from the great central
light, the son of righteousness,
and diffuse that light and glory to
those who were in darkness. By absorbing
and diffusing the light, they cause
their own light to burn brighter. The
one who receives light but does not give
it as God requires him to do will become
a receptacle of darkness.
This is a writing that we find in a
particular pamphlet written
uh about 150 years ago which seem to
show exactly what is happening here. So
the woes are pronounced upon a ch church
which walks in the sparks of their own
kindling. That makes sense to me. This
makes great sense to me. So this woe is
pronounced on the apostate people on
this planet and will hit them because
they are keeping the gospel truth away
from those that could be saved. So let's
look at the two possibilities. The fifth
and sixth trumpets represent the
numbering of Satan's followers
and the final increase in evil to the
point where God withdraws his protection
and hands the willingly ignorant over to
a retrobrate mind. Wow, that's scary.
This is in contrast to Revelation 7
where the sealed of God are numbered and
empowered to stand under his divine
protection.
The other interpretation would mean that
the fifth and sixth rep trumpet
represent judgments against Eastern
Roman Empire.
The rise of Islamic culmination Islam
culminating in the Ottoman Empire is
seen as the force to bring about its
destruction.
Now here I would like to digress from my
previous ways
and say
why not marry the two?
Why not marry them? Because Islam
makes it its goal to bring Christ down
to the level of a human.
So in a sense, it does exactly what the
church of the dark ages did by
pronouncing itself the judge in the
place of Jesus Christ. Right or wrong?
So the one is just a tool of the other.
They are actually working together to
achieve the same ends to remove Jesus
Christ as the only savior of the planet.
And it is interesting that Islam
is a religion that actively propagates
and teaches this message actively.
The others on this earth do their thing
and don't actively fight against this
particular principle or that one. But
the church of the dark ages says, "I am
the way whereby you receive salvation.
You come through me or you don't make
it." In fact, they say God has to abide
by the judgments of his priests
and to either absolve or not absolve.
Wow.
And this power says Jesus become less
than you are. So let's why not marry
them?
So, which powers displaced Bible-based
Christianity? And which philosophies
arose out of the dark ages to dethrone
Christ and deprive mankind of salvation
in him? Isn't that a good question to
ask? That there would be woes upon the
earth. Well, Islam replaced Christianity
in the cradle of Judaism. Judaism and
Christianity. Isn't that right? That's
what they did.
B. the age of rationalism and
contemporary humanism with its slogan no
deity will save us we must save
ourselves that's comes from the humanist
manifesto chapter 2 edited by courts
buffalo 1973 this is their manifest so
no deity will save us we must save
ourselves rationalism contemporary
humanism
the bible is a book of allegorories
don't worry about it this has destroyed
Christianity in the western mind and
this has destroyed it in the cradle of
Christianity. The bastion of
Christianity removed. It's replaced him
in the west and this has replaced him in
the east. So these are the powers which
dethrone Jesus Christ. So now let's go
to Revelation chapter nine. And the
fifth angel sounded and I saw a star
from from heaven. Again, we have the
star falling from heaven. Unto the earth
and to him was given the key of the
bottomless pit.
That's hell. So, whatever doctrine is
going to come now is coming straight
from the pits of hell. And he opened the
bottomless pit and there arose a smoke
out of the pit. That's in total contrast
to the smoke in the sanctuary above. As
the smoke of a great furnace and the sun
and the air were darkened by reason of
the smoke of the pit. So light is being
removed from the earth as a result of
the activity of the fifth angel.
Wow. Not the activity of the fifth angel
but the curse which comes because of
what the powers of darkness are doing.
And they came out of the smoke locusts
upon the earth and upon them was given
power as the scorpions of the earth have
power. The appearance of them is like
the appearance of horses. We've had
horses before. Concerns the gospel. Like
the noise of chariots on top of
mountains, nations. Shall they leap like
the noise of the flame of fire that
devourth the stubble as a strong people
set in battle array? And I will restore
to you the years that the locust has
eaten. That's what Joel said. So we have
the symbolism of what was happening in
literal Israel. Let's apply it to the
spiritual one. Revelation 9:4. And it
was commanded them that they should not
hurt the grass of the earth, neither any
green thing, neither any tree. So not
total destruction, but only those men
who have not the seal of God in their
forehead. So the judgments hit those
that are being numbered. And to them it
was given that they should not kill
them, but that they should be tormented.
And there's a period there, five months.
And their torment was as the torment of
a scorpion.
Jesus says, "I will give you power to
tread on scorpions when he striketh a
man. And in those days shall men seek
death and shall not find it, and shall
desire to die, and death shall flee from
them." Then there's a description of the
locusts. They are like unto horses.
We've had horses before. They
represented the gospel herald. Prepared
unto battle, and unto their heads there
were crowns like gold, and their faces
the faces of men. And they had hair as
the hair of a woman. And their teeth
were as teeth of lions, breastplates as
were breastplates of iron, sounds of
their wings, the sounds of chariots of
many horses running into battle. Here's
a war situation. So this is roughly what
they looked like. Tails of scorpions,
breastplates of iron, teeth, terrible
things, whatever. An artist's
impression. And they had tails like unto
scorpions. And there were stings in
their tails and their power was to hurt
men five months. Revelation 9:10. What
does this mean?
Well, some see in this symbolism
what Islam did and the other you could
see it in the full sense of what this
new message without Christ would do to
the world. Now let's have a look who's
over them. And they had a king over them
which is the angel of the bottomless pit
whose name in Hebrew tongue is Abadon.
Fascinating stuff this. But in the Greek
tongue has his name Apolon.
One woe is passed and behold there come
two woes more hereafter.
Okay. Well, we know some names,
interesting ones. And uh after this, one
woe upon mankind is finished. All right,
let's ask ourselves a question. Which
philosophies emerged after the dark ages
which directly undermined faith in the
Bible and Jesus Christ as the only name
under heaven whereby we can be saved?
Isn't that a good question to ask?
Which organized bodies is the next
question I have directly propagate the
obliteration of Jesus Christ as the only
name whereby we can be saved? Those are
the two questions we would like to
answer answer. Well, rationalism,
higher criticism, humanism,
spiritualism. Would you agree that those
are the powers that remove Jesus?
And then which bo organized bodies
directly propagate and obliterate the
name of Jesus Christ as the only name
whereby we can be saved? Freemasonry.
I'll give you text upon text upon text
to show that they do it. And the secret
societies,
they all are in favor of total unity and
equality of all religious founders.
Communism directly opposed the doctrines
of Jesus Christ. Formalized atheism.
That's all that communism was. And then
you have the World Council of Churches.
Is that possible? Do they actually do
that? Do they? I'm afraid so. Because
the World Council of Churches propagates
the unity of all religions under one
roof. And that means that Jesus must
become less than he is in order to reach
this compromise. Yes or no? So it's just
a fact. I'm not making this up. This is
what's happening. Islam removes Jesus
Christ. Does it or not? As the sole
savior of the work. And the United
Nations has an organization which is
called the United Religions
Organizations whose aim it is to get all
religions to accept their equality.
Well, that's fine. It sounds like a good
idea,
but what does it do to Jesus Christ? It
puts him on a level with all the others.
And then there must be many a name
whereby you can be saved. Yes or no? Is
this correct or is it not correct? You
tell me because I'm in trouble here. I'm
putting certain things up there which
are problematic.
But this is exactly what they are doing.
Communism removes him totally.
Freemasonry levels him. World Council of
Churches compromises to reach it. Islam
fights him directly. And the UN says,
"You better do it or else."
Wow, we're in trouble. Let me read this
to you. This is nisped.com. Freemasonry.
Let's read it. In the 17th degree of the
Scottish right, the sacred word
communicated to the candidate is abadon.
In the Satanic Bible by Anton Lavey on
page 145 146 Abadon and Apollon are one
of the infernal names in Satanism.
Scottish right Freemasonry Illustrated
Jay Blanchard volume 1 page 453 states
touch Tyler's forehead when he answers
by putting his hand on your forehead.
Password jibilum sacred word abadon.
Didn't we just read that this was an
evil angel? Yes or no? So, Freemasonry
says, "This is the angel over us." They
had his angel over him, Abadon, Satan.
If you look at the Islamic
interpretation,
this is the range of the desert locust.
And that is the range of early Islam.
And today, it covers that and more.
Very interesting. This was the range of
early Christianity. This was the range
of early Christianity. Do you do know
that? Today it's replaced. It's gone.
It's been removed. It's been replaced by
Islam.
Islam arose only after 600 AD and
totally remove Biblebelieving
Sabbathkeeping Christianity in the
world. Removed it,
slaughtered it.
Interesting.
And today it is forbidden
forbidden by law upon death to propagate
Jesus Christ in those countries. Isn't
that interesting?
That is a terrible woe upon mankind
because if the only name whereby you can
be saved is removed, that's it. You're
in trouble.
John William Draper also writes the
history of the intellectual development
of Europe that four years after the
death of Justinian in 571 AD was born at
Mecca in Arabia. The man who of all men
has exercised the greatest influence
upon the human race according to the
life of Muhammad. Muhammad appeared on
the scene at one of the darkest periods
in history when all civilizations from
Moravian Gaul to India were falling to
ruin or were in a state of troubled
gestation. Here we go. Great war. At the
age of 12, Muhammad traveled with his
uncle in a trade caravan to Syria. Here
he met the Christian anchorite called
Bahira.
Beholding the boy, so goes the story,
who could discern in his face marks of
the future greatness. and he advised Abu
Talib to take good care of him for he
would someday be the recipient of a
divine call. The recognition of the
prophet by Bahira the Christian
symbolizes in Islamic tradition the
primacy of Muhammad's mission over that
of Christ.
Jesus is made less. Revelation 9:4. And
it was commanded them that they should
not hurt the grass of the earth, neither
any green thing, neither any tree, but
only those men which have not the seal
of God in their forests. So who is
affected by these trumpets? God's people
or the other people? The other people.
Everybody who does not have the
opportunity now to choose Christ because
they removed it from him, they're in
trouble. And to them it was given that
they should not kill them, but they
should be tormented. Five months. And
their torment was as the torment of a
scorpion when he striketh a man. And in
those days shall men seek death and
shall not find it and shall desire to
die and death shall flee from them.
Interesting. Here's a decree of Abu Bak
Muhammad's uncle who succeeded him. When
you fight the battles of the Lord,
acquit yourselves like men without
turning your backs. But let not your
victory be stained with the blood of
women or children. Destroy not the palm
trees, nor burn any fields of corn. Cut
down no fruit trees, nor do any mischief
to the cattle. Only such as you kill
eat. When you make any covenant or
articles, stand to it and be as good as
your word. As you go on, you will find
some religious persons who live retired
in monasteries and purpose themselves to
serve God that way. Let them alone and
neither kill them nor destroy their
monasteries. And you will find another
sort of people that belong to the
synagogue of Satan who have shaven
crowns. be sure to cleave their skulls
and give no quarter till either they
turn Muhammadans or pay tribute. Well,
this decree is seen paralleled in the
Bible. And some believe that the five
months
represent 150 prophetic days, which
would be 150 prophetic years using
Numbers 14 and Ezekiel's 4 as template,
the day for a year. And so it was worked
out that if you take this number
and you take the date July 27, 1299 when
Ottoman invaded Nicamedia.
Then you add the 150 you come to July
27th July 1449 when the last Greek
emperor Constantine took the throne with
permission from the Sultan.
Now, Khaled bin alad by name Scyif
Allah, one of the two Muslim leaders of
the normally successful, enormously
successful Islamic expansion under
Muhammad and his immediate successor Abu
Bakar and Omar. Although he fought
against the prophet, the second one, he
was eventually converted, they say, and
he conquered. and Khaled remained the
effective leader of the forces that
conquered the Bzantine army. They routed
the Bzantine army. So Islam took over
where Christianity reigned. Very
interesting. And uh they went on to
conquer Syria and Arabia and destroyed
50,000 Bzantine troops and slaughtered
them. So Christianity was removed. Let's
look at the Masonic view. This is morals
and dogma. This is the Masonic source.
When Christianity had grown weak,
profitless and powerless, the Arab
restorer and icon class came like a
cleansing hurricane. But Klet, now you
know who he was. He was this great
general, the sword of God. He was
called, who had marched from victory to
victory, exclaimed to his wear soldiers,
"Let no man sleep. There will be rest
enough in the boughels of paradise.
Sweet will be the repose, never more to
be followed by labor." The faith of the
Arab had become stronger than that of
the Christian and he conquered. Wow.
This is Masonic view that the faith of
the Arab became stronger. It also says
it became a better faith than
Christianity.
So today Islam rules where Christianity
reigned. And you have the ziggurats and
the Ottoman Empire and the Blue Mosques
and Sans Sophia which all used to be
Christian domains today
Islamic domains. This one is used to be
Christian today it is Islamic. Isn't
that interesting? So if we marry the two
then we have the whole full catastrophe
of apostasy bringing in the destruction
of Jesus Christ as the sole savior.
Rationalism, higher criticism,
destruction of the Bible, removal of
faith in the Bible and in Jesus Christ
and literal war against those who
opposed them. Then the sixth angel
sounded, and I heard a voice from the
four horns of the golden altar, which is
before God, saying to the sixth angel,
which had the trumpet, "Loose the four
angels." Whoa, now we're in trouble.
Which are bound at the great river
Euphrates. So, here are four other
angels. We had four angels of God
holding the four winds. Now we have four
angels that hold the re Euphrates at the
E Euphrates. That's Babylon. So these
are the demonic counterparts to the
angelic counterparts.
And the four angels were loosed which
were prepared for an hour and a day and
a month and a year to slay a third part
of men. And the number of the army of
the horsemen were 200,000,000.
I heard the number. Can you hear? So you
have the numbering of this power and it
is an enormous number like the sands of
the seas.
So some see this time period as
prophetic time, the hour, the day, the
month, the year. And others say no, this
simply is a definitive statement of the
time. Now, this very year, this very
day, this very month, this very second,
this is when it will happen.
So whether you want the one or the other
is probably not that relevant and they
probably could both be right. Some see
this period as prophetic time, others as
a designation of the time for the
demonic forces of Babylon in contrast to
the angels of God that hold the four
winds to issue the last great events of
the controversy between Christ and
Satan. So the first woe was this
destruction of Jesus
uh as the sole savior and then I saw the
horses in vision and then they sat on
them having breastplates of fire
and he sees this whole vision of the
smoke and they're coming out and doing
their thing and a man by the name of
Josiah Lich
he took the lit literal interpretation
and he calculated when he took the hour
the day the month the
and it comes to 391 years 15 days. And
he worked out the Ottoman Empire and he
predicted the exact day when the Ottoman
Empire would fall and it actually
happened exactly like that. So here's
the one view the Islamic power there uh
officially comes to an end. The Josiah
Lich published this date two years prior
to the event. So the four sultans are
seen by some to represent literal
sultans and they even have names Aleppo,
Iconium, Damascus and Baghdad.
They see the uniforms of the Turkish
horsemen in the description as being
blue and yellow. And they see Islam in
all of this and the Ottoman Empire. So
whether you see it that way or whether
you see it the other way in terms of a
global spiritual darkening does it
really make a difference? Other
interpretations that you could have is
the spread of Arabian Islamic Empire.
Muhammad 612, founding of Baghdad, Dar
Salam 762, marking the end of the
empires 150 years, fall of
Constantinople, you get to 1844. There
are many, many interpretations. Let's
keep it simple. The trumpets herald
apostasies on this earth which number
those that are being lost. And the
removal of Jesus Christ as the herald is
of salvation is the biggest problem. The
rest of the men which were not killed by
these plagues yet repented not of the
works of their hands that they should
not worship devils. This is the point.
idols of gold, silver, brass, stone,
wood, which neither can see nor hear nor
walk, neither repented they of their
murders, nor of their sorceries, nor of
their fornication, nor of their thefts.
So the description of the second woe in
Revelation
comes in Revelation 11. And the sounding
of the seventh trumpet ushers in the
final woe, the impenitent, as the
kingdom of God comes to an end. Now, we
can't jump and do Revelation 10 and 11
all in one night. It's going to drive
you crazy. So, what we're going to do is
we're going to look at the second woe
in the next lecture.
And you will see that the most terrible
deception of all time comes in the next
woe. And then comes destruction. We are
living in the final moments before the
third woe. Now what is that final
deception that will come about? If the
second woe already remove Jesus as the
sole savior, then what will happen
before he comes with the clouds and
every eye shall see him and they which
pierced him and all kindreds of the
earth shall wail because of him. Even
so, amen.
This is the question we have to answer.
So we've seen Apollon, we've seen Abdon,
we've seen some statements where
organizations claim that this is the
power ruling them. We've seen
possibilities of Islam over here. We've
seen rationalism and popular humanism
and all these things coming in removing
the doctrine of Jesus Christ and
bringing darkness and woe upon the
people. Now, when we get to Revelation
11, we will see what the final deception
is going to be. How Satan sets up his
final kingdom to attack the word of God.
Scary stuff. And then we'll have to do
12 lectures to show that it's really
like that. May the Lord bless us and
keep us until we come together again
tomorrow for a next episode in the
series. Thank you for coming.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Oh,
hey.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
heat,
heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.